she should know we believe her yeah yeah
free brittany kathy and nikki hilton are
supporting britney spears
100 well thank you so much sweetie
the mother-daughter duo appeared on
bravo's watch what happens live with
andy cohen on wednesday
following the pop star's shocking
conservatorship hearing
and said they were team britney all the
way even though the singer admitted to
initially not believing paris hilton's
claims in her 2020 documentary this is
paris
that she was verbally and physically
abused at a boarding school when she was
17 years old
paris made the allegations in august
alleging that her time at the boarding
school was
quote torture and in britney's testimony
on wednesday
she referenced paris claims as a reason
why she never spoke openly against her
conservatorship
saying she initially didn't believe
paris allegations
and felt in turn that nobody would
believe her
but paris sister and mom are still fully
supportive of the pop icon
she should know we believe her yeah yeah
free britney such a sweet girl
and a good girl meanwhile paris who's
been friends with brittany for
over a decade has previously showed her
support for the pop star
back in august she told the sunday times
quote
it breaks my heart that people have so
much control over her
it's not fair to be an adult and be
treated like a child
i can't imagine having to live my life
like that
and more recently in may paris praised
brittany while chatting with e.t
i love her i was actually texting with
her last week and she's just
so sweet and down to earth and really an
amazing woman
and i'm just so proud of her but back to
watch what happens live
oh i'm serving it on wednesday host andy
cohen blasted brittany's dad
jamie spears calling him the jackhole of
the night
how about we all start listening to
britney
spears britney spears is not a girl she
is
she is a woman and she certainly
deserves a hell of a lot more than a
low-rent mommy dearest in a boxy suit
brittany after the courage you showed
today you are 100
stronger than yesterday and jamie if you
want to make money in the future
i suggest you better work [ __ ]
say it with me audience free bring me
andy's sentiment is echoed by samantha
stark the director of the new york times
documentary framing britney spears
who spoke with e.t on wednesday about
the singer's testimony
it was interesting to watch all the
lawyers faces as she was
saying this and it looked like everyone
was trying to have a very
expressionless face but it was
definitely dramatic and i think uh
you know when she first said like this
is abusive and you know she really
uh talked about a lot of stuff that in
our investigation it backs up exactly
what she's saying
and you know at one point she said i
didn't i haven't said anything publicly
because i didn't think anyone would
believe me
um and we i mean we believe her but also
we have
records to show that she's telling
the truth of what happened
[Music]